misty Copeland has risen to the top of
her field as a principal dancer for the
American Ballet Theatre this morning we
have a special look at the company's
newly redesigned space for relaxation a
long days of practice the refurbished
lounge is a place where dancers can take
a few minutes to unwind misty Copeland
Marcelo Gomez and Devon - sure showed
Alex Wagner how this upgrade will have a
big impact Alex good morning good
morning Nora the American Ballet Theatre
is one of the most prestigious ballet
companies in the world over its 77 year
history abt dancers have performed in
more than 139 cities in 50 countries it
is also the only major cultural
institution to tour the u.s. each year
but the company's home base while
beloved is not exactly state-of-the-art
these are the hallowed halls of the
American Ballet Theatre
we're dancers has been perfecting the
art that makes their Grace on stage look
so effortless I think that the glamor of
the building is that it was very it's a
very old building and there's such
tradition in here
Marcelo Gomez is one of the company's
principal dancers there's such history
with all these dancers that came before
us so coming into the space you kind of
don't mind that things are sort of
falling apart that the pipes are making
noises while you're trying to play the
piano you know that this place is sacred
and it's blessed and you don't take it
for granted a day as dancer is very long
so Luis Devin - sure is preparing for a
lead role in Swan Lake a lot of times
dancers come in previous to 10:00 a.m.
to warm up and get ready for the day and
then we have a hour and a half class
which is just a basic technique class
and then rehearsals range from 12 to 7
it's generally quite grueling when do
you eat literally running from Studio to
studio on our 5 on our 5 we have 5
minute breaks every hour a lot of times
to just bring food along for the day and
eat as you're running along to the next
studio
principal ballerina misty Copeland
compares their training to that of top
athletes a lot of people associate
ballet with sort of the beautiful
costumes and the music but behind the
scenes it is an inordinate amount of
blood sweat and tears it is a really
intense practice absolutely I mean we're
working like professional athletes are
and most of those athletes have
state-of-the-art buildings and the
environment they're in is very you know
high-end and you don't get the same
funding and things like that as
professional athletes and teams and so
it's difficult until recently the
dancers were spending what little
downtime they had in a dark and dated
lounge with beat-up couches folding
tables and a couple of vending machines
and it's shabby it's pretty behind Lisa
they had stained futons but you wouldn't
even let your you know college freshmen
sit on ya Amy Ashley is the editor in
chief of Architectural Digest and a
dance enthusiast she got wind of the
tired space and led an effort to
transform it into a place where dancers
can recharge comfortably obviously the
company puts their money into other
things and we can all understand that
with an arts organization but really
that lounge did not befit a world-class
arts organization and I just thought
it's a great opportunity for ad to do
what we do best which is to beautify it
an anonymous donor covered construction
costs everything else including the
designers time and all of the furniture
was donated it was really done with you
know a lot of sweat and love like ballet
like women love like ballet sweat and
love no real money in it and now I feel
like abt has a space befitting the
beauty that they create
[Applause]
we were there when the dancers got their
first look at the renovated room in
addition to the space being more
physically comfortable misdeeds it's got
to be psychologically sort of
rejuvenating to come into a room I
absolutely it's extremely important for
us to have that time mentally and
emotionally to kind of calm down and
then build back up before we go in the
studio again the timing couldn't be
better
ADT is rehearsing for its high season an
eight week run at the Metropolitan Opera
House here in New York we're doing a new
ballet every week so you know you're
rehearsing during the day for the ballet
that's coming up the following week and
you're performing something different at
night so it can get a little bit
stressful and a little bit difficult but
it's it's it's really rewarding it's
like our marathon yeah because we go
from classical to contemporary and one
week so it's very it's interesting for
us but difficult but you love it we love
it yeah it would be really difficult to
do this job and for as long as we have
if we didn't love it
what they do on stage Alex is so
beautiful you just assume they're
surrounded by beauty well they're
they're elite athletes and their
training facilities really just weren't
up to par now they have a space where
they can look at game tape and their
performances it's great and what's there
not to like about Copeland
nothing exactly